my name is Jeff dusek i am a course to
PhD candidate my involvement in the
class is I'm actually a mentor for two
of the student project team so shoot
these on one of the teams team Beverly
Ann I also worked with team art and I
took this course last year and found it
to be an incredible experience I have a
an interest in assistive technology that
stems from a grandmother who was in a
wheelchair growing up and and when I was
asked to be involved in the course this
year I was really excited to be involved
again and in a mentor capacity was was
really a great privilege in my opinion
so uh well my name is Judy nur einen I'm
course 62 which is ecs and in this class
this year I was working with beverly n
on a grip sensor that would help her
detect when her grip was slipping when
she was picking up certain objects
so I was interested in building some
sort of technology that would actually
go to someone and help them I hadn't
really done that before in a class and
on this class was I guess pretty well
advertised and I was interested in sort
of going for and just building something
even if it was just for one person and
so that's why I decided to take it
in terms of how my expectations for the
class actually correlated with what the
class was like I think that in some
circumstances it really did end up being
what i expected i got to build something
which is really exciting i learned a lot
about circuitry and sort of fields i had
never known anything about before but
was really interested in um and all of
that was really what i wanted to get out
of the class as well as like the sort of
joy for being able to make someone
something that they're going to use and
that will help them and so that made me
really happy on what I didn't think I
would get out of this class but I was
surprised too was sort of the able to
interact with people with disabilities
and sort of understand how they interact
with the world and how assistive
technology can really help someone even
if it's just like in a very small way so
I learned a lot about that and i'm glad
i took the class mate yeah so as far as
my my expectations for the course one
thing I really realized taking this last
year is that this class and and design
and iterative design in general really
force you to learn skill sets that might
not be something that you come in with
so last year we worked on kind of a
robotic arm project I'm a mechanical
engineer and so some of the electronics
and the coding we're not really in my
wheelhouse if you will so this year I
was kind of the the mech e person of the
staff so what I was hoping was to be
able to help teams that needed a little
bit more mechanical design who maybe
come from backgrounds in electrical
engineering or computer signs and stuff
that might not have that skill set and I
think maybe we pulled that off would say
you have to hear from the the team's
about that one
so when we have a collaborate with our
client a lot of it was just figuring out
what would help her out the most because
um she came and told us immediately she
was like I have this disease and I have
bad grip because of it and so we have to
spend a long time thinking about okay
well what does that mean where it is
where is what does she what parts of her
hand does she gripped with what um when
does her grip slip why does it slip on
what can we do to sort of prevent it
from slipping what device could we even
possibly make and so a lot of the time
was just spent with her talking with her
about her experiences with her disease
and sort of figuring out very very
slowly what would actually help her and
then once we were able to get to that
point it sort of snowballed from there
we were like okay we actually know what
the problem is now so we can make this
device and then it was just build build
build and then we got it done network
um so for other on students or engineers
who want to collaborate with clients
with disabilities I think that it's a
really valuable experience and you
should definitely go for it I learned a
lot and was able to help someone and I
think that in itself made me really
happy um but in terms of things to keep
in mind uh the client comes first and
you have to always remember that you are
solving their problem not what you think
their problem is and we had to spend a
really long time actually getting to the
root of a problem which is why I think
in the end our product worked so
definitely listen to the client try to
get as much critical feedback from them
as possible even though sometimes that's
hard because they're just happy that
you're there helping them even if you're
not making them what you the best thing
that you possibly could and so
definitely listen to your client would
be the advice I would give
so I think the group work went really
well we were able to split it pretty
nicely into different sections of work
on in the beginning we were all pretty
much just talking with Beverly and a lot
about her disease and her problem but
once we were able to analyze the problem
we were able to sort of pick up niches
of the design that we were able to split
up pretty evenly and work on and then
combine in the end I think I definitely
figuring out how to split the work
evenly is the hardest part but once we
were able to do that it went really
smoothly
i would say for our team in particular
none of us had any circuitry experience
coming in and we were making something
we were making a device that was going
to stay on her at all times and it
definitely required a lot of circuitry
so the biggest problem was just figuring
out what kind of technology we even had
available to use and how we could use
that to our advantage learning about how
circuits worked even at like a very
basic level all that was just so foreign
to us and so that was definitely the
hardest part to get past
yeah so so as a mentor it might have a
slightly different perspective on the
teaching of the course tonight and I
think a few things are really important
I would say as far as designed and
designed for for a client there's really
two things i would say that making sure
that you have a really good contextual
inquiry so really understand you're
crying and understand the problem i
think that's one thing that this course
does it's a little different from most
design courses as you're designing for a
single person and so you really get to
interact with that person and understand
them and understand their problem and
it's really important to do that and and
that's kind of the starting point for
everything you do and so you really need
to get that contextual inquiry and the
second thing that I learned taking the
course but then also working with the
teams this year is just the value of
iterative design and prototypes no
matter what fidelity they are so even
paper things or cardboard things true
these team with featherly and they
worked with a grip sort of project and
so they used things like putty to kind
of map where the the handgrips in
particular and those sort of things and
I think that's really valuable is making
use of even kind of non-technical
prototyping but to really kind of better
understand the design space for the
professors and the educators for this
course who are going to teach it in the
future I think that the thing most
important for them to remember is that
um I think the students all have really
good intentions but don't necessarily
know how to act on them like in our case
we were just really lost with some of
the electrical stuff until we are able
to find resources that were able to help
us and so I think the one thing they
need to keep in mind is that um we
definitely are very lost in some of the
things we have to learn how to do and so
obtaining as many resources as possible
is like very useful for us down the road
so for example in our case we were able
to use the Cypress engineering lab on
which has a lot of resources for
electrical device development but we
didn't know about it until mid-november
so until then we were sort of
floundering
and eventually we were able to get into
the lab and get a lot of work done but
knowing that earlier would have been
helpful and so just like find and
exploit all the resources you can get
because they all pay off in the end
take this class um I really really
enjoyed it it's like it's something that
I haven't gone out of a class before
because this actually went to someone it
like it wasn't just something that i
built and then dropped at the end of the
class it like is actually going to help
someone live their life in a better way
and that's just incredibly rewarding